françois hollande tout sourire pour
l'inauguration de la fiq et de la
gastronomie à côté d'un françois
rebsamen silencieux l'ancien président
esquive les questions pour ne pas gâcher
la fête question politique on au
lendemain de l'accord ps
il y aurait plein de réactions mais
quelques instants plus tard il ne peut
s'empêcher de réagir pour que la gauche
accède au pouvoir faut qu'elle soit
crédible un tacle appuyé à l'accord
signé par la direction du ps avec la
france insoumise pour marie-guite dufay
on sent que cette union c71 marche
forcée
l'état du ps si on voulait une gauche
diverse soient présentes à l'assemblée
nationale nécessité ce cet accord
maintenant pour moi c'est un point de
départ il ya beaucoup de divergences à à
travailler dès 15 circonscriptions de la
bourgogne celle de l'adresse est donc la
seule ou de parti socialiste investira
officiellement est candidat la députée
sortante cécile untermaier dans les rues
de loin on pense que l'accord à gauche
lui sera favorable mais avec quelques
réserves ll un très fort ancrage local
donc je pense que les gens vont voter
par rapport à la connaissance qu'ils ont
leurs élus sur leur circonscription
ouais je pense ça va la servir ça va
prendre à desservir non ça va être ça va
l'aider je pense ça et puis j'espère
qu'elle sera elle sera désobéissons ce
vis-à-vis des sassoum sy dans un
communiqué cécile untermaier a réagi à
son investiture par la nouvelle union
populaire économique et social en tant
que député ps sortante femme de gauche
libre je n'ai pas attendu de consignes
venues de paris pour faire campagne sur
le terrain cette alliance ne peut pas
être une allégeance je reste moi-même
une prise de distance avec l'accord
programmatique conclu entre les
différentes formations bien qu ni la
gauche reste indiscutablement pluriel